so where's all this going exactly what
can we expect over the next month or two
colonel douglas mcgregor has thought a
lot about it he's lived a lot of the
stuff he joins us now to assess doug
thanks so much for coming on where is
this going do you think
well based upon your monologue it's it's
hard to tell right now but certainly the
destination is the land of the stupids
you know what's really disturbing is
that this is the eve of the 80th
anniversary of pearl harbor an event
that dragged us into a two-front war for
which we were completely unprepared
and listening to the comments by wicker
and others it strikes me that joe biden
has lots of friends on the hill all of
which are living with him
in the early 1990s
they seem to think that russia is
prostrate that russia has no alternative
but to submit to whatever we tell it to
do which of course is ridiculous
if we challenge russia on its doorstep
and by doorstep i mean eastern ukraine
militarily we will be defeated that's
not an if that's a certainty and if we
are stupid enough to consider the use of
nuclear weapons to rescue our
conventional failure well then we're
courting the destruction of the known
world
frankly and that's something we should
avoid we have really only one interest
you asked
the key question what is our interest in
ukraine or russia in that area for for
that matter
we have one interest tucker that is to
prevent a war
from breaking out between ukraine and
russia a bloody war with implications
involving refugees and millions of
people being displaced from their homes
moving west into europe we have an
interest in preventing that we have an
interest in preventing a war in that
region that could spread rapidly across
the black sea involve turkey involve
iran we don't know
so we have an interest in doing that and
we know that if we can prevent it we
have to compromise and compromise is the
way to ensure that ukrainians the
majority of them who are ukrainian will
live in a free and independent ukraine
we're not doing any of those things
we're bent on some sort of revenge
mission which makes no sense to
humiliate and harm russia why is beyond
me this is not the soviet union this is
russia
a russian state that rests on the
foundation of orthodox christianity
it's back to what it has been for a
thousand years we should celebrate that
not try to destroy it
maybe that's one of the reasons we are
trying to destroy it
could be
he could be
douglas mcgregor a wise man i wish
you're in charge